welcome to high guardian academy  [Music]  you've each been selected for your  exceptional qualities  rosemary you're on the warrior track  your affinity for justice is clear but  we must not let the mere presence of  weapons determine our actions  don't worry guys i got this  sage is here to master magic your eons  ahead in sorcery so you'll be amazing my  family is old magic i don't do new magic  with new magic you can do anything  [Music]  you're a blacksmith yep  john  dang you're on the right track  this is war you're brutal i love it  [Music]  you want to see if you can save the  fairy woods together you can't hide this  from a friend roommate  friend  we've got to keep looking out for each  other i trust you all of you  we'll scale mountains  and fight mermaids will be totally  fearsome dude  [Music]  to victory  you